so uh before we look at the question in
detail right this is bivariate data
tell me again hopefully you wrote it on
the heading on friday what does
bivariate actually mean
by means
there's two things
and the variant means
two variables but it's like you know uh
it's like if you looked up cool in the
definition in the dictionary it's like
having the quality of coolness like yes
vary it does mean variables but variable
just means things that change yet
quantities in particular numbers things
that we can ascribe numerical value to
that are changing right so that's why
you can see over here
on the vertical axis we are not counting
the frequency of something how often
something occurs uh there's something
that's been measured here and it's a
capital v so even before reading the
question you could probably guess it's
v4
velocity is actually a very good guess
but we usually for physics students we
usually use a little v for that capital
v tends to be
volume but that's actually completely
random so there's no reason why okay now
you can see we've got um yusuf he's
conducting an experiment he recorded the
volume in liters of water let's write
that down there because that's going to
be important for understanding what this
graph is about
that flow through a pipe in a given time
of between one and six minutes so again
i'll underline that there's a
a matter of units there for us there he
repeated this procedure many times over
a period of several hours in the middle
of the day so he's a good scientist he's
repeated his observations
uh his results are shown on this scatter
plot that you can see over here and then
he's drawn a line of best fit through
the data okay so far so good understand
what's going on
i reckon we can step through these
questions together because they're
pretty straightforward so long as we
think about what they mean the first
thing is you encounter this weird word
which for anyone who missed friday we
should redefine interpolation is when
we're trying to understand something
that's not exactly in the data but
what's the difference between
interpolation what happens later
where is it gone extrapolations all the
way down in part g what's the difference
interpolation is
keegan it's like within the data and
extrapolation
perfect so when you have a look here
right um have a look over at the the
times these are all in minutes right so
the question even said it's between one
and six minutes so we would call this
within the data so that's why they're
asking us to make these predictions
about three minutes and five minutes
even though we don't have any actual
data point for those times and then as
keegan said perfectly you know if you go
past that six minute range i've got a
data over there so we are extrapolating
at this point okay
now i'm cheating a little bit because
i'm about to be able to draw on this
diagram but you will be able to do
something similar we want to look
between three and five so i'm just going
to make this very big
have a look there i'm going to help you
out by drawing a bit of a line up here
so actually maybe i'll just you know
i'll do that so if i go from three
minutes all the way up to where the line
of best fit is can you see that clearly
enough where does that look like it goes
to on that vertical axis
yeah just under six yeah now given that
this is a line of best fit and it's
approximate when you draw that of course
over you you guys are right is just
under six but it's it's approximate yeah
it's roughly so i think i'm happy to say
and maybe we can all jot this down this
is part oopsy daisy part a
part one
this is going to be six we said the
measure was leaders didn't we right
so six liters and we're going to do
something similar when we have a look
for
five minutes right so again i'm going to
draw up from five
there you go
can you guys make that out where does
that go over to on the left-hand axis
yeah nine and a half i think is about
right
or ten i think the textbook actually
says 10 but that's uh not really going
to matter too much because like i said
it's approximate okay so let's go ahead
and write part two
this is uh nine and a half to ten liters
by the way someone asked me a question
on friday when you guys are drawing
lines of best fit remember that you're
doing that little exercise on desmos and
that kind of thing we often have
uncertainty built into
our estimates and i've written nine and
a half to ten liters here
we have this thing called a confidence
interval it's a range like that interval
that you were dragging up and down on
the computer that tells you how
confident you are i think it's somewhere
in between here nine and a half to ten
liters is something like that idea of a
confidence interval
okay next thing it says estimate the
equation of the line of best fit so
we're trying to work out we would
normally say y equals mx plus b of some
some kind right but we have neither an x
nor a y axis we have a
v
and a t axis so i'm going to humbly
suggest that saying v
equals something is probably your best
bet let me pause for a minute let you
guys stare hard at that graph use the
data that you can see there on that line
of best fit
if you were coming up with a
mx plus b like a slope intercept form
you need two things don't you an
intercept and a slope the intercept's
pretty easy to read what do you see
bottom left-hand corner there
it's going through the origin so we're
going to expect i was going to say
y-intercept we're going to have a
v-intercept of
0. so
i guess i could say plus zero what's
that gradient look like to you
again it's only approximate
yeah looks like two to me right you can
kind of see down here as you go across
one you go up two across one up two an
easy way to look at it is just to go
right to the end right if i go to 6 you
can see that's pretty close to 12 yeah
so that way you take the whole data set
or the whole line into consideration so
i was going to write 2x but it's not 2x
it's 2
t
and that actually plus zero i'll get rid
of that now are you happy with that as a
rough approximate line of vestment
okay
what's the value of the intercept you
actually just told me right and why
would you expect that value you told me
the v-intercept was zero why is that a
reasonable thing to expect
what's this thing measuring again
water flowing through a pipe over a
certain amount of time so if you
measured for zero time
how much volume do you expect to go
through
no water yeah so therefore i think we
can say what is the value of the y
intercept it's zero
and why would you expect that value no
water
flows with no time
and there's not really any other way to
say that than with the words
okay now i already underlined some
things in the question that will help us
answer the next part what is the
physical meaning of the gradient so the
value of the gradient is 2 but that's
not the physical meaning of the gradient
because i could say 2 could mean like
your speed for instance that could be we
had a look at graphs that told you
distance over time that's not what this
is what's the physical meaning of this
gradient two so signify
yeah
yeah i i think that's word for word the
rate at which water flows in in liters
per minute right so why don't we all jot
that down that's the rate
of water flow
okay now i've held your hand through the
next few bits i wonder if you can do
part e through i
can you guys have a go at that
yourselves and then confer at your table
with whether you get the same answers or
different ones and then we'll come back
together in like two minutes because
everything that'll be long enough for
you guys to have a go and briefly
discuss okay off you go i don't think we
need to discuss all of these questions
there's just uh some of them that i want
to particularly focus on okay
now uh the first one is or the first one
that i let you guys do independently is
one of the ones so it says should your
soup have drawn the line down through
the origin into the third quadrant of
course what they're referring to is
you've got the first quadrant up here
the second quadrant will be over here
and then the third quadrant would be
down here okay now everyone i've spoken
to so far agrees with the textbook which
is to say
no it's silly right because not only do
you have like you know the fact that
it's down here he doesn't have any data
points down there but you're going into
negative
volume like what does that even mean
okay now i think that's a fair argument
and that's why the textbook says like
yeah he shouldn't have done that
basically okay however i just do want to
put out there some of you did say um not
just about negative volume but about
negative
time and say like well negative time
doesn't make sense
i would like to humbly suggest to you
that sometimes it
can
sometimes negative time is important in
fact sometimes you need it can anyone
give me a suggestion
as to when negative time might make
sense what do you reckon you're counting
down to this actual start
okay so if you're doing uh reverse like
a rocket's about to blast off right so
you might say okay time zero is when the
rocket blasts off but we start counting
from ten and then nine and then eight so
we're literally doing negative time
right is a really good example can
anyone give me another one
this starts at zero right
presumably yusuf did not start existing
when he started recording things right
he existed before this and most of the
data that we measure if it's over any
significant period of time like say
you're looking at a population
when do we have information about the
population of a country answer when we
started recording right but that's
probably not when the data started
existing so there would be actually data
before then it's just not measured from
time zero it'd be time negative one
negative two negative three those things
actually can be very very sensible so
just important to actually raise the
question
all right uh i do wanna do f as well i
know it looks like i'm doing every
question but i promise i'm gonna stop in
a second why do you think the
correlation in this experiment is not
perfect why don't they all lie on the
line who's got a suggestion for me
should they all lie on the lane whatever
i can daniel
the rate of water flow isn't constant
well that makes sense i mean if you have
a think he's measuring a pipe it doesn't
say anything about where that pipe is
where a pipe comes from where it's going
whether we've had torrential rain things
like that and in fact we can actually go
one better than that i think that answer
is right in concept but can you back
that from the data have a look at the
data points
and can you tell me i mean there's one
that stands out like a sore thumb can
anyone tell me
from the data why we can't possibly have
a line of best fit on which every data
point sits
hmm
now dan you gave me such a good answer
i'm going to hit pause on you for a
second but thank you
can anyone think of a particular time
for example where you suff measures it
again and again and again and he gets
well
pretty different results can you see it
can you see like this column here
between two and three minutes right they
all look roughly at about two and a half
minutes right
you've got measurements that range all
the way from
about eight liters down to one right so
he's gone for the same amount of time
and he's just gone back again and again
and again and he's gotten such wildly
divergent numbers so you're going to get
this range right and that's actually
leading into what we're going to spend
most of our time on this lesson
okay so this is why just it's life
it's a unpredictable system there's
other chaotic influences that add to it
the last question flows right from that
which is part i well the last question i
want to ask you you see if we just to
estimate how much water will flow
through the pipe in one 24 hour day why
might that kind of level of
extrapolation not be valid because
earlier on you probably said like i
think some level expatulation is okay
but this probably isn't king what do you
think
he hasn't actually gone for another time
yeah six minutes yeah very good oh
actually so yes and there's another
reason so keegan has said we've only
gone like from one to six minutes which
is a very small amount of time right to
be able to extrapolate i want more
consistency so you'd want to measure
over a longer period okay
in addition what keegan said though can
you just go back to the question with me
and this is often the issue right
there's so much literacy in mathematics
that often you get a paragraph like this
some of the hsc questions like a whole
page you have to kind of wade through to
see what's important can you see there's
actually a particular piece of
information about
when yesuf does his measurements that's
critical and makes the extrapolation to
a whole 24-hour day very problematic
rishi what are you saying
in the middle of the day
this is when he goes back again and
again and again now there are going to
be reasons why we might expect if he
said when in the middle of the night he
might get something completely different
right so therefore trying to go for a
24-hour period just don't have enough
data does that make sense so
extrapolation always something you've
got to be cautious with